[Music]
we can now see that history has failed
that male dominance
materialism reductionism and obsession
with matter all of these things that we
have been pursuing with a vengeance
since 500 bc
the sum total of all of that is a
polluted planet an alienated body
politic
and
you know the circumstances we see around
us
so this impulse throughout the 20th
century has been building toward the
arcade as i said freud young jazz
abstract expressionism house music all
of this stuff but the
central quintessence
of this archaic impulse
is shamanism
the bringing back of the first religion
the return of religion as it was
practiced for the first million years
and when you slice up this figure of the
shaman and the so-called shamanic
complex what you discover is it's about
what merciled called techniques of
ecstasy
in other words
techniques
and what these techniques all are about
is breaking down the ordinary constructs
of social and community consciousness
and replacing that with a disembodied
generalized kind
of
field
of consciousness
that fills more than newtonian space
and that anchors the society allows
magic to be done allows curing to happen
knits people together causes the anxiety
of facing death to be assuaged so forth
and so on well i believe that
individually and collectively
this is our
challenge
that
that history is like a psychedelic
experience and that we are now somewhere
deep in our tomb
about to go over the top
wave after wave of invention religious
imagery conversion language technology
obsession has come and gone
in the past five or six thousand years
each wave
ratcheting us further and further up the
scale of intense involvement with our
own cognitive processes and the
downloading of those processes into
matter in the form of technology and the
question is you know where is it leading
history cannot be conceived of as
continuing for thousands of years into
the uncharted future history is some
kind of chain reaction which quickly
consumes all available resources and
forces the system to mutate
to a higher level of organization
and you know with a cup of ayahuasca
in one hand
and
keyboard access into the internet in the
other hand you can begin to see
the dim outlines of what it is going to
be
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you